voilà et comme par magie la fée amélie
réapparaît sur ce plateau faudrait
tautou bonsoir
alors ce film est un enchantement un
bijou une merveille je ne dis pas ça
parce que france 3 la co produit c'est
tout simplement les critiques qui disent
ça dans tous les magazines cette semaine
de tels compliments vous vous rassure ou
vous inquiète
ah non non ça me rassure un seul
inquiète pas je suis ravi et très fiers
de participer à ce film et je suis
d'accord avec eux alors depuis sa plus
tendre enfance amélie n'a pas eu en fait
la culture du bonheur chez elle bien au
contraire et pourtant fait elle fait
elle crée du bonheur autour d'elle c'est
paradoxal ça non
bah oui parce que je crois qu'elle est
assez solitaire et introverti et du coup
elle a beaucoup travaillé son
imagination parce qu'elle était assez
seule et elle va faire le bonheur des
autres mais je pense parce que aussi
parce que elle s'ennuie peut-être un
petit peu dans sa vie quoi justement
fait le bonheur des autres c'est plus
facile que de faire de créer son propre
bonheur oui je pense puis elle a elle a
un peu peur d'aller se cogner à la vie
donc du coup elle préfère intervenir
dans le destin des gens qui l'entourent
l'ordre dans le film il ya une fabuleuse
galerie de portraits avec eux des
personnages hauts en couleur interprété
par des vraies gueules de cinéma et
c'est pas péjoratif pour qui amélie
selon vous at elle le plus d'affection
owni nocquet campoy je crois ça c'est de
l'amour c'est pas de l'affection solide
et pas moi j'aime beaucoup la relation
qu'elle a avec le peintre l'homme 9
heures comme de verre qui peut pas
sortir de chez lui parce que comme il a
des eaux
c'est une maladie en verre cisco ni elle
est très proche de lui c'est à dire la
déclenche l'amour avec avec nos quatre
quincampoix oui je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de pudeur et j'aime la façon
qu'ils ont de se parler à travers ce
tableau alors audrey tautou est ce que
vous croyez vous au fabuleux destin
d'audrey tautou
il faut dire que vous avez eu de la
chance ou où c'est votre destin ou c'est
le talent peut-être d'ailleurs mais
votre premier film peuvent vénus beauté
vous décroché le césar du meilleur
espoir pour amélie au départ vous
n'étiez pas prévu dans le casting
et puis tout va bien
le succès bah oui pour l'instant tout va
bien je suis contente je me dis j'espère
que ça c'est pas qu'on dansait sur deux
ans pour que maintenant pendant 15 ans
et se passe plus rien vous alors vous
avez entendu dans le reportage de
richard tripot jean pierre jeunet le
réalisateur parler de vous il dit que
vous êtes une véritable actrice de de
composition etc selon lui est très rare
chez les comédiennes de votre génération
c'est très gentil pour vous c'est pas
forcément sympa pour pour les autres
vous allez vous faire des copines là non
ça je sais pas non mais je pense que bon
compose toujours un petit peu un
personnage mais c'est vrai que on n'a
peut-être pas aussi forcément l'occasion
souvent dans des films de pouvoir oser
autant de choses en tout cas d'un oui
dans la composition
mais bon je sais passage alors une
dernière question en forme de clin
d'oeil
audrey dans le film beaucoup de
personnages sont présentés sur le mode
du j'aime j'aime pas vous aimez jouer au
j'aime j'aime pas oui j'aime mais j'ai
pas des exemples aussi fédérateur que
ceux de jean-pierre bain un petit
exemple pour nous par exemple j'aime pas
les gens qui croque dans les glaçons et
vous aimez il j'aime j'aime l'odeur de
l'essence
c'est original merci audrey tautou
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour finir cette image toujours aussi
spectacle